We know Olivia can travel 30 miles, so we'll have her distance as 30. And
Terrance can go 15 miles, so his distance would be 15. And here's where we
want to be careful. We can either let x be Olivia's rate or Terrance's rate. We
know Olivia can go 4 miles per hour faster than Terrance. So we'll just add
four to whatever Terrance's rate is. We don't know Terrance's rate, so I think
it's best to use x here. If we do this, Terrance will be x and Olivia will be
four more than that, four x plus four. And finally, to find the time, we'll
take the distance of Olivia and divide it by her rate. So the time is 30
divided by x plus 4. We do the same thing for Terrance, since his time would be
distance divided by rate, or 15 divided by x.